hey everybody I welcome act super
architects today I'm doing something
slightly different from my usual videos
I'm doing a showcase of Busch Gardens
which is a park made by coaster B and
I'm doing this first and foremost
because he approached me about it
because his computer can barely run the
park anymore and I think you'll see in a
few minutes why this park is insanely
huge and insanely detailed and I won't
really have the best performance so I'm
sorry if this video comes out choppy in
any case but whatever happens my
performance is a lot better than his so
I'm kind of showcasing this park in his
place and I really wanted to accept the
offer because he's a longtime player of
architects who I really respect he plays
the game in a very different way than I
do since he focuses on realism and
detail and he uses a lot of mods which I
typically don't do since I tend to play
the game vanilla and focus on gameplay
but I think this provides a really
interesting angle into the game and
provides you guys who might not watch
his channel and are mostly just familiar
with my content into what park text can
also be because I think this is a really
cool game when it comes to UGC and
highly detailed custom content like this
because it kind of has a sort of
miniatures style you're at once very
much immersed in a realistic park but at
the same time you're much more removed
from it than you would be in planet
coaster for instance so you can keep
things less detailed and more up to
imagination while at the same time
really putting a lot of effort into
realism I know that might sound a bit
contradictory but to me at least the
comparison to a miniature really kind of
holds because it has a very similar sort
of aesthetic and a similar way of
downgrading some elements while keeping
it overall very realistic and I think
that's something that you'll see in the
rest of this park
anyway I'll link a link to the park and
to a coaster B's Steam Workshop as well
as this channel
in the description if I don't forget
about it in the case I do please let me
know and yeah let's get started
I decided to start off with showing the
parking lots because that's also when he
started with in his youtube series on
this park and I'll try to generally
follow the general line that he was
going through in his youtube series
because this park is made up of
different areas so I'll try to hit them
up chronologically and that should
hopefully make sense now the parking
lots isn't too big because as he said he
didn't want half of the map to be
parking lots which I totally respect at
the end of the day the park tech map is
not that huge and its biggest and this
parking lot already does an amazing job
at showcasing a somewhat realistic
parking lot set up I'm actually not
entirely sure how this would work I
think we've got just the regular road
over here and then we have these on
ramps going into this toll booth and
then this is the exit road as also
demarcated by all of the arrows and
everything and to me it all just looks
really realistic and believable it's
definitely down scaled it's not a
realistic size for parking lots at all
but I think it provides a very
believable backdrop for the park itself
and a nice context for the entrance area
which I think I'll just go into
straightaway as well so from the parking
lots or the the bus stop over here which
is a really nice detail you go into the
entrance area where we have some ticket
booths and finally the gates to get into
the the park itself and I think from
this point onwards I can really start
noting some of the similarities that
this park has with the real-life Busch
Gardens parks and real life there are
two Busch Gardens parks both owned by
SeaWorld and they both have a similar
kind of concept they have different
themed lands with actually quite intense
and well-known rollercoasters in them as
well but what's it really interesting is
that they share very similar kinds
right for every while major coaster in
Busch Gardens Tampa there's a
counterpart in Busch Gardens
Williamsburg there are a few exceptions
but generally they have very similar
rights just in different themes
different color schemes different
overall setups and this park kind of
plays into that so a lot of the major
rides and areas that you'll see in this
park will be very similar or based off
of real-life counterparts but at the
same time everything in this park is
very much unique and it's just using
Busch Gardens as a guideline anyway with
that introduction out of the way we go
into this general entrance area which is
quite generic still but I already really
like the detail on a lot of this and if
you play Park attacked vanilla you might
barely recognize any of the pieces that
are used in here and I have to say I
recognize that almost all of this is
made with custom pieces but at the same
time I never really build with mods so I
can't really recognize exactly which
sets he used to build all of these
buildings so unfortunately I'm sorry I
can't really give too many tips on that
but as far as I am into the the whole
modding world of parks like this looks
absolutely amazing just the the general
way that it's all laid out and the
general setup of this sort of more
generic entrance area which then
transitions into more themed lands I
think is very clever and even from a
crowd control perspective the way that
the entrance is set up definitely looks
like the kind of entrance that is made
to deal with very large crowds as you'll
typically see in a Busch Gardens park I
hope the rain is not going to continue
for too long there we go perfect anyway
moving into the first themed land which
has a German flag but I think this land
is mostly meant to be Bavarian to be
fair outside of Germany there's sort of
stereotypical idea of what German
culture is like is more or less Bavarian
culture but yeah this is the Bavarian
area with a really big beer hall over
here a few flat rides and it's starship
attraction here
is the wooden coaster now this wooden
coaster is I've heard kind of based on
Heidi the ride in plopsaland or Invader
which i actually forgot where that one
is
but yeah it's a it's a GCI wooden
coaster and it's quite small really the
only critique that I could have on it is
that it's a bit short it's really just a
few hills and then it's back into the
station
but this coaster mostly just serves very
much a scenery kind of function it
provides a backdrop for this whole area
which it does really neatly and overall
it just fits very well into the park so
I can see that you know the way that he
built the layout here is more to serve
the layout of the park and to create an
overall landscape rather than to build
the best coaster layout by itself but I
think that's also kind of fair and in
the end it's still a fun layout with
some elements that look surprisingly GCI
like like this turn around I could
definitely see that on a DCI down to the
shaping of it which is really impressive
I also have to say for the people who
are not into Park attacks modded why's
that he uses a lot of coaster anarchy on
these layouts so you definitely wouldn't
be able to achieve this layout with the
vanilla game for instance we have a
curve over here which is a 45 degree
curve that curves downward which is
something that you can't really do in
the base game especially not with
different inclined slopes and things
like that so he's definitely being very
flexible with the the coaster editor
that you can't really do with the
vanilla game but at the end of the day
it's still very similar to vanilla
coasters you just have a few extra
options with coaster anarchy but yeah I
think it all comes together really
neatly especially the buildings around
this area I think are really nice I
really like this station building with
those iconic flower boxes everywhere and
especially this building which is
covering the the transfer track or at
least the entry into the dispenser it's
back here
and also serves as the entrance to the
queue I think that's very well set up
over all the layouts of this whole area
is really nice and I guess coming back
to what I've been talking to what I've
been talking about at the start of this
video that's one of the things that I
really appreciate about Park attacks and
to an extent also rollercoaster tycoon 2
compared to non isometric games like
planet coaster it really allows you to
focus on the layout of a park because
you'll never be able to see it from
ground level you can really focus just
on how you think how you place things
and in general I think that results in
parks that are more well laid out than
the typical planet coaster park which is
often just a bunch of attractions and
rollercoasters connected with more
narrow paths which is also fair and I've
seen beautiful parks in planet coaster
as well of course but in games like
poetic I think the focus tends to be
much more on layouts and on these wide
plans are like areas which is a bit more
realistic at least as long as you have
some degree of suspense of disbelief in
a sense that everything is quite
undetailed and you kind of have to fill
in the gaps with your with your mind so
to speak also I like the Maypole over
here I think it's a bit over the top
though I think in real life they would
typically only have one of these rings
of I don't know exactly what's a column
but these are these greenery foliage
around these maples and there's even the
Bavarian flag in here using some flank
pieces which is really cool so yeah
overall I think the German area is quite
neat even though it's quite a small area
it's very well contained and with the
wooden coaster I think it even
transitions quite well into the next
area as well but I'm not going to move
there yet because at first I want to
move into what is according to coaster
be the wienie of the entrance area and I
can definitely see that this is what is
it called again Apophis which is if I
pronounced that correctly
because I think neither of us know how
to pronounce it exactly but yeah this is
a kind of the centerpiece of the
entrance area and if you are familiar
with Busch Gardens temper I think you
can instantly recognize that this
coaster is the counterparts to cheetah
hunt which is a family launched coaster
by intamin and it has that same kind of
figure 8 shape at the start here and
it's kind of weeny in a sense that it's
ours over the entrance area and kind of
draws people into that direction which i
think is super cool it's very well laid
out they can talking about the layout
here and the way that it fits into this
area is quite neat it kind of takes me
back to the roller coaster tycoon three
years when Cheetah Hunt was just built
because I definitely remember that back
then everybody was building Cheetah Hunt
inspired coasters because that whole
figure Eight's
thing it was totally unique and really
inspiring to a lot of people and it's
cool to see something similar to that
again I also really like the color
scheme on this I know the color scheme
is just taken from Cobras curse but it
fits really well into the area as well
and there's just something about purple
trek and turquoise supports or vice
versa that I really like this is always
one of my favourite color schemes and
it's really cool to see it very well
applied in this area speaking of which
this is an Egyptian area and I have to
be honest I'm not too much of an experts
when it comes to Egyptian theming but
there's really just a lot of ruins
scattered around a lot of sandy textures
and to me overall it seems quite
believable there's a really nice degree
of detail in this actually let me go
ahead and put on a quick POV for you
here so you can see it go around the
figure eight which by the way this is
all totally coaster Anarchy it would be
difficult to build it this way in
but yeah I really like the scenery
around this area I also like the way
that he tackled the coaster nets as you
can see here some coaster nets over
these parts and every now and then these
coaster nets get really creative because
realistically you need to have some kind
of cover underneath the coaster track to
prevent loose articles from falling onto
people and there are some really clever
ways that he went ahead and put covers
underneath the coaster track
which I really like one of my favorite
parts is with this Pavillion over here
which has a really cool support
structure using the coaster supports to
support the nets as well and it really
kind of just integrates it into the area
and even makes it a border between this
generic area into what is properly the
Egyptian area here which is also kind of
demarcated by the paths changing so
there's a lot of attention really put
into details like that which I really
like these lanterns around here are
really cool as well overall I really dig
the foliage in these planters there's a
really good mix of shrubs and trees in
here that I could probably kind of learn
from as well for my scenario play
throughs I really like the use or the
mix of some of these plants or shrubs
and then the regular shrubs and that
actually looks really nice and then
elsewhere in this area we have this
submarine ride which is one that I've
never actually built because I'm not a
really big fan of it but this looks like
a nice family ride that makes very good
use of the the terrain around here with
some really cool pavilions and bridges
with these paths there's a really good
sense of interaction between the ride
and the paths and the queue line path
around it see at the end that's the
Egyptian area basically which looks
really good and there's even a good
sense of transitions between these
different areas I think as well with the
generic entrance area kinda forming a
transition between Egyptian and Bavarian
and then the river and the wooden
coaster for
more of a bridge over here between these
two areas and going down here I think
this was one of the later additions to
the park though but we we also have this
generic kind of eating area with
buildings that don't really fit into any
of the theme lands but are more sort of
a transition between them which looks
really nice despite being very generic
and not too detailed now moving on from
there and this is maybe my favorite area
in the park
although yeah I think so I remember a
few months ago he sent me a discord
message looking for advice on Russian
architecture and I had to excuse myself
because I literally don't know anything
about it
and he just went ahead and tried it on
his own and I have to say it looks
absolutely amazing just this building in
general is one of the most stunning
builds in this whole park I really love
the detail on these spires the the
textures and the use of color on this
building is absolutely amazing it was
such a layered and detailed building
overall which is really just a simple
food court in function I believe but it
just fits really well it sets the stage
for the Russian area around it really
well and it's a perfect weenie as well I
mean again this is an isometric game but
if you think yourself into the mind of a
guest walking around here you could
really see this building
towering over this this area with the
river as you're walking into this
direction and going into the Russian
area which would be a really good way to
introduce guests into this area draw
them over here and yeah just in general
set the stage for this area now we have
two rollercoasters to look into in here
I'm gonna look at samarco first because
this is the the less interesting one I
suppose not that it's not really well
done but this is just an off-the-shelf
skyrocket to buy more a sauna both of
the Busch Gardens parks have these in
real life we have
tygris in Busch Gardens Tampa and some
pesto I think in Busch Gardens
Williamsburg Williamsburg there we go
but the way that he did it in pike sex
is actually quite interesting because
you can't really do the back and forth
launch like these things have in real
life it's just one simple launch going
upwards here but then using a long
strike on the top here just to get it to
the top
all right that's taking ages I'm
actually just gonna oh there we go
I always kind of turn down the maximum
waiting time but there we go
so it launches forwards and then in real
life we're gonna have it backwards
launch as well which I think it doesn't
here because that's not really possible
but then it launches up all the way over
here anyway and then it's dragged up to
the top and then it goes quite slow
through the barrel roll and then you
have in real life some holding breaks
that go over the drop but that's not
really possible in product X but I think
this small break over here is a decent
way to get around it my only gripe with
this is the barrel roll over here which
in real life is a non-inverting loop
which here is super tight but yeah
there's really no other way to do this
in Pike tech so I guess you kind of just
have to do this here overall though it's
a really amazing recreation of the
skyrocket too and I really respect what
he made here especially this station
building is actually super cool wait I
think I should probably set it to 3 laps
because I don't think it should be going
around that much but yeah anyway this is
an amazing recreation and I really love
the station it's super detailed there's
so much woodwork on here and just all of
the little pieces that he put together
because some things to keep in mind is
that all of these pieces aren't just a
single piece he really put all of these
tiny little steps everywhere to get this
Russian wooden detailing which is super
cool so yeah I really love this ride I
am personally not the biggest fan of
these kind of rocket 2 models I've only
done the one in Holiday Park which is a
scream I think but just those restraints
kind of killed
for me but it's a really cool layout
nonetheless and especially for the the
little space that they take it's just a
really cool thrill ride now moving on
the other coaster here is Alka nose
which is another one of these mythical
creatures I think which is the bnm
inverts in the park and both Busch
Gardens also have been inverts we have
alpengeist in Busch Gardens Williamsburg
and Monceau in Busch Gardens Tampa and
yeah I could say that this ride is kind
of based on both of those as well but
you know it's a B and M inverse B and M
inverts are always kind of similar they
always do a similar kind of thing but
yeah this is a really cool coaster that
has a lot of interaction with the
terrain and with the scenery as well I'm
basically just waiting at this point for
it to start so I think I'm just gonna
fast forward there we go and then we'll
do a quick view V of this coaster as
well maybe from this perspective
especially the first drop looks a bit
better from this perspective as well
also I have to correct myself I think I
just said coaster anarchy every time but
it's actually track edits that you use
to make these track pieces that you
normally can't and you need coaster
Anarchy to put corkscrews on coasters
that normally can't have them or things
like that I remember actually because I
accidentally left coaster Anarchy on
which I had to install for this park
when I did my orchard acres playthrough
and people noticed that I was able to
build a corkscrew on my Jr coaster which
I was not supposed to do so yeah that
happened
but I have to say I only left coaster
Anarchy on accidentally during that
playthrough and I had no other months
still installed so yeah I didn't really
cheat or anything on orchard acres but
that's why I had some weird coaster
options but yeah that's the coaster
that's the inverted coaster for some
reason it just keeps raining god I guess
that's maybe the climate settings anyway
yeah I really like this inverts it's
very realistic it's def
got a very believable layout it's got a
bit of a short queue though that's the
one thing I guess I could say about this
you could definitely use a little bit
more of a queue but altogether really
cool layouts I really like the the
interaction that it has with some of the
path work and some of the buildings over
here as well
and just how many times it goes down
into the ground as well very similar to
months ago in that sense which also has
some of those carvings into the ground
with a bit of scenery and then the
foliage around it it's just it's very
similar it really feels like a Busch
Gardens coaster well at the same time
it's definitely very unique as well and
you know while it's based on Montu and
alpengeist it's very different from
those two coasters as well anyway moving
on from Nets I think transitioning from
this more generic kind of area into the
Japanese area it's probably a good idea
I think this was the next area in the
park that was built chronologically and
the flagship attraction of this area is
just an arrow looping coaster so nothing
too exciting here but I really liked
that he added this more kind of
traditional classic coaster Busch
Gardens of course has Loch Ness monster
which is one of the most picturesque
coasters in the world with those
interlocking loops and I think which
Conan's temper had one of these as well
I'm actually not sure if they still do
but yeah whatever the case both parks
have had classic arrow looping coasters
and in general when you're building an
American Park it's just kind of
something you have to have these things
were all over the place in the 80s as
far as the layout goes it's quite
standard
just have simple turn around into a lift
Hill classic with those classic Aero
lift Hill supports and then into a drop
which is quite interesting and then the
two loops and the two corkscrews as
these coasters typically have I would
love to actually do a POV on this as
well I really wonder what the guests are
doing here though
that's a bit of a mess hmm is this the
cue line I mean what is up with this I
guess this is the queue line anyway what
will forget about those people let's
just do a quick POV if this goes through
oops
now I remember also that Costa we had
some concerns about the the Japanese
nests of this area because well at least
he admitted himself not to have too much
knowledge of Asian architecture and to
that I have to say you know as much over
a Japanese architecture geek as I am I'm
also still just a weeaboo from the West
definitely not too knowledgeable I do
and at the end of the day it's also just
a theme park I don't think it matters
too much if it's slightly inconsistent
or inaccurate because at the end of the
day most theme parks will be much more
inaccurate than most people building
stuff in Pike tech that blended coaster
art and I think I could definitely say
the same for this as well this area
overall very much feels Japanese and
definitely doesn't feel Korean or
Chinese even if some of the individual
parts might not be that Japanese I
really like the the torii gates on the
entrances
they're quite creative they definitely
don't look like actual torii gates are
supposed to but they look very much
inspired by real torii gates which I
think it's just the kind of thing that a
theme park like Busch Gardens would do
so I really love these very creative use
of pieces as well we have this sort of
garden area with the pond with the
walkways over it and the waterfall the
the cherry blossom trees and then the
tea houses which is just iconic looks
very Japanese I really like this even
some of the bushes these rounder bushes
scattered around the rock work really
reminiscent of Japanese gardens and you
guys all know how much I love my
Japanese gardens so yeah I approve of
this honestly it looks super cool really
the only thing that I don't like as much
I suppose is the station
which feels a bit blocky and simple and
the use of colors I'm not the biggest
fan of it definitely doesn't look as
Japanese as the rest of the area
Japanese buildings tend to be a bit more
simple in terms of colors and even if
you do have buildings with red walls
they'll typically just have black roofs
and in general these roofs are also
meant to be overhanging and that's I
suppose my biggest issue with this I
think it would be better to have just
open walls here just have pillars so
that the roofs are actually overhanging
because fitting into the climates of
Japan's crazy continents or island I
should say is a really important reason
historically for the way that
architecture that Japanese architecture
has shaped itself throughout the
centuries and it's very much in response
to the earthquakes and typhoons and the
humid weather and everything and for all
those reasons and also apparently some
beliefs about ghosts and stuff they tend
to have large open houses with moveable
walls and very much overhanging roofs so
that's the one thing that I suppose I
would change about this station and the
pagoda actually looks super cool it's
just missing the the spire with the
details on it if you look up pagodas
Japanese pagodas always have a large
spire on top with a bunch of rings I
think seven rings I swear that's not an
ariana grande reference but I don't
exactly recall the number it's
definitely an odd number but yeah I
think those might be seven rings but in
any case they have those spires that's
the one thing that's kind of missing
here but aside from that's like those
are really my only knit picks this area
is also really cool and something that I
should point out that I haven't really
looked at so far is I like the use of
Tara painting as well just very subtle
those little well those little spots of
orange and dark green everywhere just
add a slight touch or variation to the
terraforming and
it's definitely something I could learn
from as well and it's something you see
all over the park as well but I found it
really most striking in the Japanese
area here so yeah I'm leaving the
Japanese area here
one last thing this coaster is called
fujibayashi and I also don't know what
this means
I I don't know if coasts really found
out yet but yeah Fuji I think it's just
the mountain but then by actually I'm
not entirely sure but I do know that it
was probably inspired by Fujiyama in
fuji-q highland I know you kind of lost
the name of whatever Fuji type coaster
this was named after but yeah I think
it's probably Fujiyama close to me just
in case you didn't look into that later
there's that I suppose little the facts
for you unfortunately I've never been
able to write Fujiyama
but yeah looks like a pretty cool
coaster oh I should also say I
personally haven't been to either of the
Busch Gardens park ooh and I should also
say I personally haven't been to either
of the Busch Gardens parks but I know
coaster B has been to Busch Gardens
Tampa at least but we've definitely both
looked into these parks very much for me
at least it's long been an inspiration
just because these bikes are so well
able to combine the thrills with scenery
anyway moving into the next area which
you can probably guess by this flag is
going to be Brazil it's a shame you
can't get the text in around the blue
area with this like ribbon then it has
over it the Brazilian flag is super cool
it's one of my favourite flag designs
even though it has the small text on it
which according to Roman Mars action
excellence flag ologists I know there's
an actual word for it but I'm not even
gonna try to pronounce it today it's
quite late but yeah even though
according to him you shouldn't have
small text on your flag
I think the Brazilian flag absolutely
rocks it's super cool and this Brazilian
area in general is really cool as well
I'm kind of going off the chronological
path because this was the last
to be ended but from the Japanese area
you just flow into this area too well so
yeah here we are
we have two coasters here we have Grover
Samba which is a very nice play on
Grover's Alpine Express I like that
gone I'll always remember Grover's
Alpine Express for this one meme
comparing it to sex yeah I know my taste
that means it's weird I'm sorry that's
just me I just I just love this me
anyway yeah this this coaster is based
on the standard zero Tivoli 190 I've
only been on one of these I've been to a
lot of parks with these coasters but I'm
not that much of a credit [ __ ] to ride
all of them but I have been on the 190
in kolmården I always find this kind of
a weird layouts because most of the
layout isn't actually the layout itself
it's just like I think the majority of
track is the final brake run the turn
before the list on the Left arrow itself
this sort of flat area after the lift
Hill and then the actual layout is just
too little helixes I think it's a bit
weird I think they could have done more
with that layouts but who am I to judge
I it's very well recreated in Park
thanks here so I can't really complain
too much about that and I like the
station design also with the detailing
on the side it's a very simple station
but it manages to set itself apart in
the detailing and just in general all of
these colourful buildings the neon palm
trees everything this whole kind of
Fiesta theme really comes together here
oh and I love this assets I'm pretty
sure this assets is on the Steam
Workshop with the name it's your boy
Jesus and because one of my favourite
Steam Workshop submissions on Planet X
it's awesome and this is a very good
integration it's a game I'd say also I
like the lockers over here that's a nice
touch then I hadn't noticed before
actually and the queue is kind of making
its rounds around the back here and yeah
I should probably show the coaster
itself this is carnival hype
because we gotta be hyped for a bnm
hypercoaster
this is I suppose based on Apollo's
chariots in Busch Gardens Williamsburg
there is the car very conveniently let's
give it a quick POV I really like the
supports on this
it's very realistically B&M hyper I also
have to add all of the support work on
all of the coasters is completely custom
that's not something that comes with the
game and even all of the flanges and the
footers and even the bolts on the
footers are all added manually so a lot
of work has gone into making these
layouts look realistic so that's
something I really want to point out
just how much work goes into this but
yeah this layouts is quite simple quite
standard fare for a bnm hypercoaster
I suppose but it God it just looks
really cool the way that way it makes
its way around the log flume and it
ranks with the dive machine it's super
cool I really like this hyper especially
for how it looks this this whole lift
hill structure here with the the chain
return and even the way that the the
supports are built around the way back
into the brake run and the log flume
here it's just it's absolutely perfect I
really love it I wish I could have more
constructive criticism but really the
reason that I'm showing off this park is
because I think it's one of the best
examples of what you can do in Pike
techs and it makes the game look really
good and it deserves more recognition so
yeah here goes anyway that's that's the
Brazilian area and moving on to the
american 50's kind of area here we have
our last major attraction which is the
dive coaster as you might see it's not
actually a dive coaster but it's a
floorless coaster because we don't have
a diving coaster in protect yet I'm
saying yet but that's actually not based
on anything we just don't have a BM dive
coaster in Pike think it would be cool
to see one in the future but I have no
idea about that
I swear anyway this is the dive coaster
based on Griffin and Busch Gardens
Williamsburg and SheiKra and Busch
Gardens Tampa which i think was the
first dive coaster in the US and
definitely one of the most picturesque
knife coasters I think definitely one
that kind of set the stage for many dive
coasters before it obviously the whole
dive coaster trend started with oblivion
in Alton Towers and coaster be said that
he likes knife coasters and even
oblivion but I have to be I don't know I
have to disagree here i I think dive
coasters are not that interesting I
think they just run out of steam too
quickly and beyond the vertical drop
they don't really have anything to offer
then again Chikara is a bigger dive
coaster which means that it's bigger
than some of the mini dives like Baron
1898 and oblivion and cracker here in
Europe and with that it even has a
mid-course bake run which is how you can
tell that despite the fact that this
coaster has tiny little Florida scars
it is definitely supposed to be a big
hyper or dive coaster so I'm just gonna
do a quick POV here so you get an idea
of what this looks like
I also like that it has a near-miss
elements on the bottom here with this
kind of winged rider looking structure
so yeah you go underneath the parts
which is kind of the tunnel of this ride
into this Immelman which looks so good
and into the mid-course brake run the
drop after which is not quite that much
of a dive but I think overall in the
layout it fits very well and finally
into another Immelman and then an
over-banked curve into the final brake
run so yeah
this layout doesn't do too much but then
again that's just what break and what
dive coasters do I think it's just
really realistic in that sense I really
want to point out the station on this I
really love this the way that you kind
of have this sort of destroyed
post-apocalyptic could prove here with
those support sticking out it's really
cool this giant overhanging roof
structure in general is super impressive
and I really
that about it that aside we just have
some pedestrian bridges here and a small
diner here and that through 50s American
style and that rounds up the entire park
and yeah also here you can see he went
the extra mile on some of these last
coasters with even the bolts on the
footers and you have to keep in mind
everything on this is custom its the
supports they have to place the the
footers themselves and then the white
parts on the top of the footer and then
finally the bolts and these really even
look like actual bnm dive coaster
supports which are typically the track
also is quite thick unfortunately while
Park Tech doesn't have a dive coaster so
you don't have dive coaster track but
altogether with these supports it just
looks very dive coaster ask so that's
also something I really have to applaud
here I know I'm just giving compliments
all over the place here this is just
such a cool Park and such an inspiration
really and such an amazing showcase of
what you can do in Pike tanks despite
the fact that it's lagging like how at
the moment because there are a thousand
guests in the park and the park is
absolutely huge but yeah that is
basically all of the park and there
might have been some small things that
I've missed here and there I highly
recommend to check out the park yourself
you can find the link to the Steam
Workshop page in the description which
will also have all of the mods and
assets that you need to open it so that
should be no problem and also check out
coaster beast you know if you want to
see more stuff like this I believe at
the moment he's still working on his
super realistic B&M coaster he finished
this part quite a while ago and he's
already been doing a bunch of stuff
since then so yeah check out his channel
if you're interested in more stuff like
this as well as for all of the people
who are always asking me if I'm ever
going to do a similar sandbox style
playthrough I'm thinking about it but
before I do that I definitely want to
finish all of the campaigns in Pocket X
so yes I would love to do a sandbox park
at some
means but I don't see it happening in
the foreseeable future because for now I
keep or at least I want to keep focusing
on the the campaign and keeping it all
vanilla God this video turned out to be
a long one didn't it anyway that's all
for me I'd like to thank you guys for
watching and I hope to see you in the
next episode of pike texts in which i'll
be back to good old vanilla campaign
mode bye guys